This just in - airplanes are disgusting, disease-ridden
sesspools ready to infect you and everyone
you love at a moment's notice.
Have a great trip!
Hey guys Tara here for Dnews - and if you're
gonna be doing some summer traveling soon
- then it's worth reminding yourself how gross
airplanes actually are.
A new study from Auburn University finds that
microbes can live up to 8 days inside an airplane,
just long enough to infect you and ruin your
entire vacation.
A team of researchers sterilized 6 different
surfaces on the inside of an airplane - and
then purposefully infected them with a host
of microbes, ranging from E coli to MRSA,
the antibiotic-resistant staph infection that's
estimated to occur in around 1-2% of US citizens.
Their goal was to see how long these microbes
could survive in an airplane cabin, where
they're most likely to proliferate, and what
the chances are of them actually infecting
someone.
Turns out - there are a few different places
bacteria love to thrive - and the worst one
is the airplane seat pocket.
MRSA was especially attracted to this area,
surviving up to 168 hours - or around 8 days.
E. coli, on the other hand, tends to thrive
in the rubber armrest, and was able to survive
up to 4 days there.
The 4 other germiest areas of the cabin were
leather seats, plastic window shades, plastic
tray tables, and toilet handles.
Despite what you might think, though - the
dirtiest places aren't always the most likely
to transmit infections.
The researchers in this study found that the
most porous surfaces - like the rubber arm
rests - do harbor the longest-living bacteria,
but also have a lower risk of infection because
the microbes tend to bury themselves deep
into the pores of the material.
On the flipside, non-porous surfaces - like
the toilet handle - hold fewer microbes with
shorter lifespans, but they're way more likely
to infect you than a place like the seat pocket.
Other studies on airplane germs have come
up with some interesting conclusions.
A 2007 study found that 60% of airplane tray
tables, tested positive for MRSA.
Other experts caution against staying in aisle
seats - since they come into contact with
more people, and are thus more likely to transmit
infectious microbes.
Obviously keeping yourself hydrated is important
too, since the low humidity on board can lower
our natural defense system.
But the overwhelming consensus, across all
studies, is to avoid the airplane restrooms
at all costs.
You may remember a while back, there were
several cases of fecal bacteria discovered
in the water supply of airplanes.
As a result, the EPA passed the Aircraft Drinking
Water Rule which ensures safe and reliable
drinking water for passengers and crew.
But germs like E Coli can still survive in
airplane sinks, as long as people who are
infected with it, are washing their hands.
And you know that tiny airplane soap isn't
gonna get rid of that stuff.
Now obviously, the ideal solution would be
for airlines to adopt the same sanitation
strategies as places like hospitals, which
use peroxide vapors and UV light to disinfect.
But until that happens - if you're really
concerned about getting sick - your best option
is to avoid the bathroom altogether.
And if you MUST use it - wash your hands thoroughly,
and then douse yourself in hand sanitizer
afterwards.
Maybe not your whole body, but at least your
hands.
Hopefully this hasn't scared you out of traveling
this holiday weekend - but to be honest, I
kind of hope it has.
I'm gonna be traveling myself, and I wouldn't
hate having an empty seat next to me.
You know, for hygiene purposes.
Anyway, if you ARE gonna be traveling - and
you're looking for something to fill your
time, look no further than Audible.com.
Audible is the leading provider of downloadable
digital audiobooks and spoken word entertainment.
They've got over 100,000 titles to choose
from, in every genre you like.
Just download them to your iPod or MP3 player,
load em up, and you're good to go!
If you're looking for recommendations, I suggest
checking out Daily Rituals: How Artists Work.
It gives a peek into the everyday - and often
strange - habits of some of your creative
minds.
Head over to audiblepodcast.com/dnews, and
we will hook you up with a FREE audiobook
download of your choice just for signing up.
Again that is audiblepodcast.com/dnews - to
get your free audiobook, and remember, every
sign-up helps support Dnews.
As always if you guys have questions, comments,
newfound phobias of airplane cabins - feel
free to leave them in the comments below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!